la ryder cup 2018 c'est pour bientôt
dans un peu plus d'un an les regards
seront tournés vers le golf de saint
quentin en yvelines qui dit compétition
internationale des affluences de public
la ryder cup c'est emblématique
effectivement pour les yvelines parce
que c'est la première fois en france qui
à ce concours mondial du golf dans les
yvelines et en particulier à saint
quentin en yvelines
donc c'est ses 80 mille personnes qui
vont venir chaque jour à saint quentin
et qui éventuellement vont le soir
visiter ou revenir par la suite pour
justement visiter notre département
les retombées économiques de la
compétition sont évalués entre 90 et 100
millions d'euros la ryder cup est
intégré à la cinquième édition du 12
piques touristes
l'idée c'est d'accompagner les
professionnels du tourisme dans
l'accueil et notamment des touristes et
de l'accueil des touristes étrangers
l'accueil c'est le sourire c'est la
maîtrise de la langue c'est le petit
geste que l'on est capable de faire
lorsqu'on sait que on a une clientèle
asiatique des plus attentive à telle
chose qu'une clientèle sud américaine
qui serait attentive à autre chose un
guide pratique un site internet et une
application sont proposés le sport
devraient continuer à attirer du public
en cas d'attribution des jeux olympiques
en 2024